Welcome back everyone it's Charlie
This will be my full Invincibles
Season 2 Episode 4 Video
It's the midseason finale
There's a whole bunch Easter Eggs and references.
There is a lot, a lot of stuff to cover.
And I'll explain what's happening
with the second half of the season.
So if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
Gabriel four spoilers for the episode.
If you haven't seen it yet,
we'll start at the beginning and work our way through.
Shot by shore Talking about Easter eggs in the many
the many WTF moments
They really wanted to end the first half of the season.
Like get ready for this break with a strong finish.
And they did so metaphorically and literally.
Papa Bless it's a very father son.
Cat's in the cradle kind of episode
the episode title was It's Been a While,
which is a reference to what OnDemand said
at the end of last week's episode.
At the beginning of this episode, because this episode
basically begins after a quick backstory montage
for Omni-Man, right
where they ended in last week's episode.
basically Mark seeing him again on anthrax,
learning the truth about why he brought him here.
And it's basically the first time since he left
that he's seeing him not that much time has gone by.
It's been less than a year
because the three Texans live for less than a year.
and basically it brings up all these emotions, this
trauma that Mark had been ignoring this whole time.
That's part of the reason why he'd been burying himself
in his work for Cecil in the Global Defense Agency,
not only to prove to everyone that he wasn't
going to turn out to be another omni-man, But also so
that he'd be so busy he wouldn't have time to think
about everything that happened and how it affected him.
so even though they kind of speed run
their first Father-Son chat
since the chaos of season one
they still do kind of have a talk with each other.
They don't really have time to actually sit down
and really chat it out though.
That'll eventually come.
the actual opening scene is basically
Omni-Man is BackStory
showing what happened to him right
after he left the Planet in the season one finale.
The soundtrack is to Nick Cave's avalanche.
you can basically see that he flew through the vacuum
of space long enough for his beard to grow out.
So it's been a while, like it's been a number of weeks
he's been flying through the vacuum of space
because they're kind of meant
to be a parody of the kryptonians,
like the Superman character,
like he's an evil version of Superman, so to speak.
his abilities, basically holding his breath
while he's in space, flying around through the vacuum
is similar to the way that Superman can fly around
of the vacuum of space without a helmet on.
but they kind of get into the weeds,
like the technicality, the practicality,
the whole physics of this.
Later in the episode
when Mark almost tries to leave the planet and fly back
home, Omni-Man has to tell like,
No, dude, there's no way you'd make it home.
First you get lost in second.
You don't know how to hold your breath out long.
basically what they show you during
this montage is
that Omni-Man would stop off briefly at planets
when he needed to recharge his lungs
like he couldn't hold his breath indefinitely.
but is basically what is happening just enabling him
to fly from planet to planet that do have atmospheres
with air that he can breathe in remember, there aren't
that many habitable planets across the universe.
basically, this winds up turning into like a long, dark
night of the soul that just last for weeks and weeks.
And notice how close he gets to the black hole here
is because he's thinking about killing himself,
just letting himself
sort of drift in to answer the follow up
question, like, would a black hole
actually be enough to kill a Viltrumite?
Might? The answer is yes.
Like you can kill Viltrumites,
as he does at the end of this episode,
like he ways of killing the other Viltrumite soldiers
it is a very, very,
very hard to do that, especially depending
on their each individual strength level.
Like not all built
rights are or created equal For instance,
thorax is still the most powerful Viltrumite
at the moment,
even though Invincible himself has the potential
to become the most powerful Viltrumite.
But that's still a long ways off for him.
basically he winds up being saved
because the three axons
almost accidentally fall into the gravity
well of the black hole.
He saves them in
that basically saves his life indirectly.
he takes them back, he learns about their race thorax
and they convince him to stay,
if only just for a little while at first
to tell them about himself in the idea
is that he starts to find a measure of redemption
in ruling over their plan as a benevolent leader,
as oppose to the village from its traditional ways.
The way that thread rules over the build from its way,
harsher way, more brutal, as evidenced by the Viltrumite
soldiers that show up later in the episode.
most of their people are
like that all the time
like they're not even trying to be aggressive.
Like, that's just normal attitude for Viltrumites.
thus begins the redemption of Omni-Man.
So I've talked about this in previous videos,
but the idea is that even though Invincible
is called Invincible because it's about the Mark
Grayson Invincible character, a big part of the story
is also the redemption of Omni-Man you basically see
the beginning of that during this episode.
pretty much all of this storyline on Thorax is right
out of the comics.
There were a couple of minor changes
like they changed a couple,
the build for my characters, but they're all based
on the comic book versions of the characters.
so when he steps up to him and it seems like
they might fight, but then he breaks down
and just hugs him like he misses him so much
and he just can't hold it in anymore.
That's how it went down in the comics.
you could tell
Omni-Man is kind of tensing up there, too, like he's
starting to clench like, we going to have a fight here
in his defense, though,
even though he seems kind of like a butthole
during some of these scenes,
the idea is that Omni-Man was raised a certain way
to think like these other Viltrumites
do from birth, essentially.
he's a couple thousand years old in present day
right here
even though he seems like a middle aged man
just because of the way that built from Ice Age.
and he'd only been on Earth for like the last 20 years.
so for like thousands of years he'd been conditioned
to think the way that those other village might think
it's only recently that his time on earth
has caused him
to change his stance
and cause him to think a different way.
they kind of get into this later in the episode
when Art is talking to Debi about
why Invincible also turned out
so good because of her influence.
I'll talk about that
when we get to that part of the episode,
because it confirmed a couple of my fan theories.
when he references Omni-Man knocking his teeth out
before the ultra mice
are capable of healing from that kind of damage like,
you know, basically fixing his teeth.
Whereas normal adults cannot regrow teeth.
it explains how they can get beaten
within an inch of their lives, then rebound super quick
like Omni-Man seems like he gets his spine broken
in this episode, which would kill a normal person.
But because he's built right, he's so strong
he can't heal that.
that does it make them absolutely unkillable
or invincible?
Just very, very hard to kill.
Omni-Man
then explains how he became emperor of the three Axons,
basically the custom on the thorax and planet is that
the oldest member of their race becomes their leader.
But in any given time they only live for about a year.
Their leader would die pretty quickly.
So when Omni-Man comes along and they see that
he doesn't die like he just lives forever,
and he has superpowers.
He's like the clear choice with him.
Like, Please become our leader.
So he's trying to explain to Mark
that there was no fight. Like.
No, no, no.
They actually have a really good relationship with me
and I with them.
They ask me nicely to become their leader and
I'm trying to rule them in a benevolent kind of way.
he meets his new thorax and wife
who's a totally nice person. it.
Notice Mark's face
when he says that he can never return home to Earth.
he actually looks disappointed,
as if for his sake, like even though he was super mad
about what happened during the events in season one,
he was hoping just a small
part of him
was hoping that he might come back at some point.
then they introduce him to his
younger half brother, Oliver,
Rubik WTF moment and I love the way
they do the title treatment too.
Like they do the title trope.
But this time.
The sentence sounds a little bit weird.
Like it rolls off the tongue a little bit weird.
basically dropping the invincible title with a pause
while he's in the middle of dropping an F-bomb.
these are to explain some of the logic
behind his little brother Oliver
in his thorax and half with his Viltrumite half
and how he's aging a little bit faster
The whole idea is that his abilities will be about
the same is invincible as abilities once he matures.
But because of his thorax.
And half He won't become nearly as old.
Like he'll still age relatively faster.
typically though with fractions,
they mature very, very fast.
so that's
why even though he was only born a couple of months
ago, he'll age to maturity and get his powers
way faster than Mark did.
once he does reach maturity,
though, then his aging will start to slow down.
I think the idea is that these Thraxian Viltrumite
half breeds will only live for up
to like a couple hundred years.
Whereas say like Mark, who's half human Viltrumite
well live
for potentially thousands
and thousands of years full blooded Viltrumite
like Omni-Man, though, could theoretically
live for hundreds of thousands of years.
But the reason why nobody's actually been able to test
this theory
is because the scourge virus
almost wiped out their entire race.
otherwise you might actually see
some Viltrumites out there
that are really, really getting up there in age.
They jump back to Debbie on Earth.
She's still walking aimlessly around town
after her encounter with Alana's husband.
It's meant to be a parallel for the walkabout
that Omni-Man just went on, so to speak,
More like a fly about through the cosmos.
Just like Omni-Man.
She also thinks about killing herself,
almost jumping off the overpass.
She's basically hit rock bottom
in the same way that he did.
part of the reason for paralleling their arc
like showing
this scene for her
is because eventually they will meet again.
The two of them will meet again.
so they want to show that by that point
they both gotten to a better place
mentally and emotionally by the time that that happens.
but it's still a long ways off
she visits his fake tombstone at the cemetery.
And when she asked why he bothered marrying her,
there were actually two reasons.
At first, she was just the first person who he met
that basically fit
the criteria that the mission thread gave to him.
Infiltrate the local populace,
sire a half breed built right with them,
then use them to take over the planet.
But remember.
He was with her for a couple of years
before Invincible was born.
So the idea is that over those first couple of years,
they actually fell in love.
And that's why they got married.
like he actually did love her
and her influence actually was very positive on him
in part of the reason why he wasn't able
to kill Invincible at the end of season one.
later in the episode when he complains to Mark,
Why am I having these feelings?
I'm still trauma.
I'm not supposed to feel this way.
It's because of the positive influence
of Debbie on him.
it's kind of the same situation
with Superman and Lois Lane.
Lois Lane is meant to be his tie
to humanity, basically.
they kind of got into this during the Justice League.
Snyder Cut where Lois Lane dies and Superman falls
prey to dark side in the anti-life equation.
Turning into, like, the evil version of Superman it's
meant to show you
basically what could happen to Superman
if Lois Lane were not around.
the whole idea, though, is
that Omni-Man does did love for a kind of
still does love her,
but she doesn't know that at this point.
they mentioned this in the episode.
The reason why he called her a pet was basically
so that it would make it easier for him
to take over the planet
because if he sort of thinking of her as his wife
is the person that he loves, it's harder
for him to do that.
when he was saying all those terrible things during
season one, that was basically just to make himself
forget about all these feelings that he had for Earth
and his family.
by the end of this episode, he's
kind of embracing those feelings.
like I said, the redemption of Omni-Man.
He's letting himself feel all of the feelings.
Then we go back to the molars
because there's another clone.
Now they have a joke about which one is the clone,
this time being the first time
that they know exactly who is the clone
and who's the original.
Because the original has half of his body
almost burned off.
they use this for like a comedy runner
during the episode with him just kind of joking back
and forth about who's subservient and who's the master,
because they got into that during season one.
But the whole idea is their dynamic is usually that
neither one knows who the original is,
so neither one ever feels truly superior
to the other one in that's meant to keep them in check.
Keep them from killing each other, so to speak.
they introduce
the Donald storyline who's trying to visit Debbie,
trying to figure out why she was acting so weird
the other day.
That's also a bit of a runner during the episode
to where he starts to finally figure out what's
really going on with him, and they basically give you
all the answers that you need.
If you haven't figured out, don't worry,
we'll talk about that in a second
because it's a big WTF moment
at the end of the episode.
But here.
He finds his glasses in the rubble,
starting to put the pieces together.
The whole idea is that he doesn't have the memories
of when he died.
back at the university.
Amber and William joke about cutting class and wasting
money because it costs a fortune to pay for college.
So if you're skipping class,
you're basically burning money.
hindsight being 2020, I also agree with Amber.
when I was actually going to college, though,
I would have also been the same way as well.
You're not really thinking about the actual cost
I've been lucky enough
to get a four year scholarship
that covered almost all of my tuition.
Not everything, but it did make college super cheap
but I was super lucky because I think nowadays
is that the like 60 almost $70,000 per year
just to go to college.
And it's just like a regular college.
Artemis visits looking for Mark,
who hasn't been answering his decks
because as they explain, he's on the mission to Thorax,
even though they don't know that it's secretly Omni-Man
tricked into coming to Drax a Ambersons.
It's been about a week.
That's because it took him almost six days
just to get there, and he just got there.
They also use this scene to show you
how close Atom is getting to mark
how their relationship
is slowly developing in the background.
The two of them are alike
in that they both have super messed up home
lives and super tragic origin stories,
so they kind of bond over that.
if you haven't seen it.
I did like a full breakdown
Easter Eggs video for that Atom Eve prequel episode.
I'll post the link for it down in the description below
because it's a great episode,
but it is super messed up
They revealed the place that Atom Eve keeps in
the city on the deal is really just the teen
team's old lair invincible.
I actually visited there during season one,
then back on thorax.
Mark tries
to wrap his head around the existence of Oliver,
basically paying off Omni-Man threat from season
one rabies.
Is that all he had to do was kill Mark
and then just go sire another son
in a wait another 17 years
and I'll just make another one.
turns out it took way less time than 17 years.
that Omni-Man basically explains
why Oliver needs Mark's protection.
Because the Village of Mice has special rules
about who they can interbreed with.
In the view Oliver is substandard.
So even though right now through the other Viltrumites
their army would view Oliver is an abomination.
That's going to change. So say your clocks for that.
Just remember that in the background,
they'll turn a big 180 on that interbreeding policy.
Remember the three axons grow to maturity super fast.
So if you were a Viltrumite
and you wanted to create a build a Viltrumite Army
super quickly,
they actually be a really easy way to do that.
Easy-Bake Oven. They'll try Army.
so. Omni-Man.
As for Invincible is helping killing the other Viltrumites
in making the fight a little more even.
It's meant to also pay off
statuses comments from last week
Mary was wondering if having both Omni-Man
and Invincible working with the coalition of planets
would be enough to stand against the Viltrumite empire
like not just one but two
Viltrumites working with us
The whole battle that goes down in this episode
is kind of like a template, a preview for what
the final battle between them in three
Mag is going to look like at the end of the show
eventually.
like, if you thought that this was a crazy battle,
like a lot of WTF moments, just imagine how much bigger
it's going to get when there are a bunch
of Viltrumites involved a taste of things to come.
then of course the episode isn't that long.
The minute that he agrees to train
with Omni-Man to learn how to fight better,
the Viltrumites show up like, Nope, no time for that.
We got to fight Then back at the teen team's
lair, Atom finds Killcanon and trying to steal tech.
The robot left when they went
to the Guardians of the Globe then back on track.
So all this stuff is from the comics Invincible.
Arriving at the caves of Rocklin,
there are people use the caves as a shelter
during periodic massive lightning storms
that went back to their ancestors.
but part of the joke is their lifespans are so short.
They've been through so many generations.
They were so long ago,
they don't remember why the caves were called remotely
like we don't know who Rocklin was.
then if it wasn't clear this Viltrumite soldier
Lucan comes
to the caves
actually looking for invincible to fight him.
That's why he explains the whole logic
of how this is going to work.
Like if you survive our fight,
if you fight well, you'll be allowed
to enter the build to my army, It's
not until he shows up
and they get ready to start their fight
that he actually notices that Oliver's there.
And he's like, Wait a minute.
There's another son.
The desired then tries to kill them both.
Basically Invincible isn't quite the match for him,
but Omni-Man shows up and ends things pretty quickly.
They're pretty evenly matched,
but the whole idea is that Omni-Man is older than Lucan
in more experienced fighter
and that's why he's able to end the fight much quicker.
but the fight is another good example
of how hard it is to actually kill Bill.
To me, it's like it seems like he's pretty dead,
but nope, he is not dead.
anime makes fun of kill canon using more tropes
like his one thing is just using his arm cannon
to shoot stuff, even though it's been powered up extra
because of whatever robot was using in that device.
their fight winds up turning into another reminder
about her thinking of collateral damage in the well
being of bystanders almost getting a couple of people
killed while trying to fight kill Cannon.
even though her father totally sucks, but he wasn't
wrong about superheroes, mostly
just thinking of themselves, their fights,
whatever they're doing at any given moment in
not about the issue of collateral damage.
Then Mark Hamill comes back as if he didn't realize
Mark Hamill does the voice of art here
coming to visit Debbie, basically talk her
through their shared trauma and give her the pep talk
that she's been needing for a while, that she was
strong enough on her own to make it through all this.
for the most part, she raised Mark by herself
because Omni-Man was always off
fighting some other big adventure.
thank you very much to Luke Skywalker
for the sage wisdom.
art also confirms
one of my theories I've had for a while.
So when Angstrom Levy said
that this main universe version of Invincible
was actually an anomaly in the multiverse
because the vast majority of the other versions
of Invincible across the multiverse turned evil.
Joining Omni-Man to take over their planets.
so art is basically confirming my theory
that it was actually
his mother's influence on him in this universe
that prevented that from happening.
And for whatever reason in these other universes, his
mother was just never around when he was growing up.
Either
she was dead or Omni-Man killed her after he was born.
in like I said, at the end of the episode,
when Omni-Man talks about his redemption, like,
why am I feeling all these feelings?
Why do I care about these people?
It's because of the positive influence of Debbie on him
back of the Global Defense
Agency, Donald finally learns what's been going
on, why everyone's acting so weird around him.
He's essentially a cyborg created by Cecil
using the memories
and consciousness from the original Donald,
kind of a similar back up situation.
Tech that the mullahs use in preserving
their consciousness by just putting that in new bodies.
any of that,
they're not super explicit about what's happening,
what he's seeing in the bathroom,
when the knife bends, when he stabs himself,
essentially it's him realizing that he's a cyborg
and he has the metal parts underneath his skin.
That's why the knife bent in his
why he has no memory of blowing himself up,
because he so basically just took the backup copy
and put it in a new body in
the backup was made before the explosion
back on anthrax, a omni-man invincible fight.
The other two village mites, Vidor and Tula Thewlis,
kind of like a parody of Ursa from the DC Comics.
Like Ursa Non inside. And
she's also voiced by Gray
Delisle, who's also mostly known
for doing the voice of Azula back in the day.
She's done a million other voices, too,
but she is giving off some azula energy.
notice how she's grown her hair into a ponytail
and woven a blade
to the end of it,
using it as an extra weapon in combat.
That's how badass the fighter she is.
and because victories are so strong, it's
basically like choking Mark out with super strong rope.
The visor here also gives him
some eradicator vibes too.
We're talking about Superman
Kryptonian parodies here with the Viltrumites
Omni-Man tries to make Mark realize that unless he goes
no holds barred and tries to kill the Viltrumites,
they will kill him like kill or be killed.
Which is very much a bill to my way of thinking.
But the whole idea here is it's
Mark's morality sort of kicking in saying like,
No, no, no, I do not kill people.
That's not me.
even though for a hot second, it seems like
he does relent and try to actually start killing her.
they want to show you that there's always a chance,
like a chance that he could lose it
and start acting more like Omni-Man.
But the whole idea is the positive influence
of his friends, like Atom
his mother,
everybody else keep him from doing that.
Most of the time,
they're basically the people that humanize him.
they have a crazy a crazy WTF montage
of all of them just wrecking each other.
Omni-Man almost ends the fight
with the two Viltrumites almost being dead.
Maybe not quite, but pretty dead.
Until Lukin
seemingly breaks his spine with the surprise attack,
carrying his own guts with him
all the way from the cave.
Like that's how hard it is to kill Viltrumites
he calls the Belgium army to basically come in
and pick up Omni-Man, take him into custody.
then they go back to their home to reference the books
that he wrote under the pseudonym Nolan,
under his real life persona, to set up
that twist at the end of the episode
to basically tells Invincible, Read my books.
As in there's secrets about the true history
of the Viltrumites in those books.
also this book, Savage Planet Savage Beast, is a meta
reference to their adventure
this week on anthrax as well.
Debbie giving Nolan's money from the books to charity
is also them taking
a step further away from Cecil
and the Guardians of the Globe.
Like there's a wedge between Cecil and Invincible
that's slowly growing that will continue to get worse.
is part of the reason why Cecil continues developing
all those contingency plans for killing Viltrumites
and there getting better every day
the baseball gloves are also a reminder
that she's the one
that helped play catch with Mark when he was a kid
because Omni-Man was always away so much.
And when they get back,
like when Invincible gets back with Oliver,
they'll use it to play catch with the two of them.
Because the whole idea is they'll have to take Oliver
back to Earth to keep him safe.
Now that the Viltrumites have omni-man in custody
and they're letting Mark go free
because he's survived the battle.
So the whole idea is that he feels like he can't leave
Oliver on Thorax now at the mercy of the Viltrumites
because they know of his existence.
also the idea that the positive influence
of his mother,
like this whole family life on Earth, helped Invincible
become a good person.
he'll probably hope
that the same thing will happen with Oliver too.
when Omni-Man tells him to read his books,
I think he picks up on the message like his eye
twitches a little bit, like he kind of realizes
what he's actually saying to him as the bill provides.
Card him a way to be executed
like the whole idea is that he wrote these books
to earn money while he was on planet
Earth under the fake Nolan identity.
But he used his own true history, the history,
the filter, by passing it off as science fiction.
essentially, it's like secret code for Mark to learn on
how to kill Viltrumites
the Invincible Gun book is a reference
on how to kill Viltrumites
Some details on the scourge virus to Then Atom
Eve, in the wake of almost getting those bystanders
killed, goes back to her parent's house
to try and make amends with them.
Just kind of deal with things in general.
And general
Kregg The Viltrumite army shows up
as they're carting omni-man off in the dead
bodies of the other Viltrumites and he's voiced
by Clancy Brown probably sounded familiar.
he was also just on the boys.
Jem The TV show is sort of like
an evil version of Professor X.
He tells Mark that he's part of the Viltrumite army.
Now, whether he likes it or not,
it has to take up Omni-Man original mission,
preparing Earth for their eventual takeover, or else
they'll come in force and kill millions of people,
basically putting a ticking clock on the Viltrumites
invasion of earth, like a much faster ticking clock.
That was before during the post-credits scene,
the Mueller twins
have more jokes about the original forcing
the new clone to refer to him as the king,
basically wait on him hand and foot,
say he's going to create an army of clones.
Like why have one one? I could have many.
then promptly gets killed by the brand new clone.
And when he says sometimes
things are the way they are for a good reason,
he's talking about why
there's only ever two of them at any given time.
The rule of Seth. The rule of two.
Because otherwise
the Muellers would start their own little civil war.
If there were a bunch of them,
nothing would ever get done
because they'd always be fighting each other
for supremacy.
presumably, right after this moment, he's
going to create another clone in this time
because they'll look identical.
Neither one will know truly who's the original
and who's the brand new one, So neither one will feel
truly superior to the other and they'll start working
like they used to work together.
There was a whole bunch of stuff
that happened in the episode Hobbit, Easter
Eggs and references from the comics.
So if there's anything you spotted that
I didn't talk about during the video or any Easter eggs
or references, just write up below in the comments.
But what's going to happen now is that Episode five
like the rest of the season,
the rest of the four episodes will air early next year.
They haven't said exactly when that's going to be yet,
but the whole idea is that right after this, Mark
is going to have to take Oliver back to Earth, start
preparing Earth for the village, for my army
to show up like all of his friends, Atom
everybody else, Cecil, the Guardians of the Globe.
if we're talking about more village mites
coming to check on them, like he said,
we will come check on you soon.
he's mostly
talking about Innis and eventually Conquest.
But Anissa is the first one to show up.
we might get some teasers for her at the end of season
two or sometime during season three.
It's still like a little while.
There's a lot that happens before anything shows up,
but when she does
there is a bunch a bunch of messed up stuff
that goes down.
Don't worry.
There will be a lot that we will talk about
when she actually shows up on the show.
They're couple other Invincible videos
that I'm working on.
So be sure to enable alerts from my channel
so you don't miss those.
Is a bunch of big stuff
coming up to the next big animated series
that'll be happening will be
what if that'll basically be at the end of the year?
Click Here for my What If Season two trailer and click here
for All My Invincible Videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!